imagine what would happen if you
suddenly decided to become a doctor
spend the next seven to eight years
having to absorb endless information on
human anatomy physiology pharmacology
behavior communication alongside skills
and applications all into your brain
that's what i decided to do and between
sometimes shitty lectures council
teaching and worldwide global events a
lot of this learning has not actually
happened in the lecture theater or in
hospital but it has had to be
self-taught so as any other medical
student i have spent a significant
proportion of my 20s just learning and
the single most life-changing skill i
have taught myself is how to teach
myself so today i thought i would
completely break down and show you the
step-by-step process that i use to teach
myself especially very difficult topics
to learn in a way that makes them
digestible memorable and above all
applicable and interesting this will be
a combination of my own personal
experience tips that i've gained from
reading the books of the most excellent
teachers in the world and also a bunch
of evidence-based research around the
human memory brain and learning let's
get straight into it there was this
general consensus that neurology is a
very difficult topic to study so for the
purpose of this video i'm going to break
down how i would study one topic in
neurology which is multiple sclerosis so
i have a six step process of which the
very first step is called broadening the
context and what i will be doing here is
placing this topic in a broader context
in the world and in my brain for it to
make sense because at the moment
multiple sclerosis is just a chapter in
a textbook or some questions in my exam
i don't particularly care about this
there's many chapters in many textbooks
there's no inherent curiosity in me to
go oh my god i must know what this is
about and before you say well you spend
a lot of money in university and if you
don't study properly then you're not
going to pass your exams this is not
enough incentive for me to actually
study things properly or care about the
things that i study so i need to place
this in a broader context in order for
it to make more sense and excite me a
bit more words in a textbook not
exciting real life world much more
exciting richard feyman one of the best
teachers in the world identified this
phenomenon when he said i have to
understand the world you see so he felt
very very strongly that people have an
inherent curiosity about how things in
the world work and this is what i try to
leverage before i study anything that is
difficult i need to put my curiosity
about this topic and my emotional
investment in this topic at the maximum
level it can reach and at the moment
it's just non-existent multiple
sclerosis couldn't care less so let's
make it very interesting for elizabeth
now the way that i will do this is that
i will go to google and i will google
multiple sclerosis and i will go to the
news tab but what i'm looking here is
for some sort of media case this is not
going to be the studies of new drugs
being found because again i'm just not
interested in this enough at the moment
this will be is there some celebrity who
has it is there someone who died because
of it is there some huge controversy
around this because i know that my brain
is much more likely to kind of attach to
these interesting things than it's to
attach to a list of molecules which i
don't kind of recognize at the moment so
still there's no textbook here i'm just
on google and i am searching for
um something related to multiple
sclerosis and what i found this is going
to work perfectly so this is a guardian
piece on selma blair discussing her
history with muscle scarces ideal
absolutely ideal i don't know who this
lady is but she looks like she's famous
so this is a famous person that i can
identify the disease with and what i'm
going to do at this stage is that i am
going to kind of read this and place it
in my mind if i just read about multiple
sclerosis in a book there's nothing that
can connect it to pre-existing things in
my mind because there's no slot for
multiple sclerosis in my mind at the
moment there's something around
neurology and yes i can identify facts
here and there but if i'm just treating
every single chapter as just random
facts they're all going to kind of
disconnect at some point and not make
any sense so what i'm leveraging instead
of my random science fact is i'm
leveraging my curiosity and my
understanding of the world in a much
more layman sort of way in a way that
anyone would understand and if this is
written on the guardian i'm absolutely
sure that everyone will understand while
i'm reading this i'm going to be picking
out things that stand out to me that i
know that i can anchor to now what
anchoring is is connecting things from
my pre-existing strong memory to things
that are specific to multiple sclerosis
and i want this connection to be as
strong as possible so therefore this
context is really really strong so let's
have a look she's describing her
childhood i'm going to be picturing her
every time that i read these things so
it says that she's suffered from
multiple symptoms that come and go okay
so this is very interesting there's a
bit here about her going to florida on a
holiday and this is interesting because
it's florida specifically which is
really warm i can remember that and then
she was a
trip for instagram so paid influencer
thing she bought a tiny bikini and an
hermes shoes okay very fancy so they're
on a yacht again really strong imagery
here going on in my mind and what
happened here was unfortunately when she
was on the water she couldn't move okay
so she jumped into off the yacht and
then she was kind of paralyzed she
thought she was paralyzed she couldn't
control her limbs she couldn't swim in
the water okay this is a very strong
visual experience for me someone in kind
of a tiny bikini and in hermes uh shoes
jumping off a boat she probably didn't
have the shoes on but in my mind um
jumping off the boat into the sea cannot
move okay this is very strong imagery
good so
then we move on so what happens is that
yep she had a romberg's test
okay
um she ordered an mri on the spot she
talks a lot about how no one had ordered
her mris in the past okay oh again very
very good there's a part where she
speaks about using a cane at a celebrity
event which again something quite rare
that we don't get to see she was crying
quite a lot unfortunately i'll bless her
interesting there are times when
okay so there's times when both she pees
the dog pees in the house and she pees
herself because she can't she probably
has some urinary incontinence here
okay interesting there's a lot of visual
stuff here so there's a lot of
information here related to multiple
sclerosis which is probably quite
similar to the list of symptoms i would
be getting in a textbook but in this
case they are being anchored to so many
things in my brain so i'm thinking
yachts i'm thinking summer blair i'm
thinking canes i'm thinking dogs i'm
thinking um peeing one's trousers i'm
thinking um
not be sometimes dancing sometimes not
being able to move so there's all of
these things i'm building a very strong
picture in my mind and i'm anchoring it
specifically to this individual so thank
her so much for writing this article and
i think there's a book on this somewhere
so um this has mean that i've put this
neurological condition into context now
i'm going to be focusing on step number
two which has to do with emotional
implications and what this means is that
if there is a very very challenging
topic i need to make sure that i am
fully emotionally primed to tackle this
and what this means is that i need to
understand the consequences of not
learning it and understand the benefits
of learning it and also try to convince
myself or try to frame it in a way that
i am genuinely itching to do this this
is the dopamine section of this um study
method dopamine is a neurotransmitter
which is related to our anticipation of
something when we are anticipating
something exciting dopamine increases in
our brain and we really really want to
do this thing so this is what i'm trying
to do with these sort of topics so at
the moment yes i'm slightly interested
in her story but again there's many
stories out there why would i
specifically want to learn about
multiple sclerosis so because we know
that the scarcest interest is desire we
want to go for the desire angle here so
i'm going to go back to the article and
see what is something interesting here
what is something about future me that
might be interested is there something
that particularly might make me kind of
compelled to learn more so okay i think
the part that stands out to me the most
was that she's been misdiagnosed her
whole life in turn especially there's
this segment when she said when she got
diagnosed she said she felt an
adrenaline rush of emotion it felt like
giving birth the release of it and i've
gone through this myself when you get a
diagnosis for something that you've had
your whole life and you suddenly
understand what that thing is it can be
so so so absolutely relieving and
life-changing and it's such a
bittersweet but mostly sweet moment and
i can't really relate to her with this
thing and so i don't have multiple
sclerosis but i can see how she must
have felt in some ways in some capacity
with her experience so now i'm
emotionally invested now i know that
this is one of those conditions that
sometimes gets missed that sometimes is
misdiagnosed that apparently some very
few tests could have found so for her it
was a positive romberg's test and an mri
so now i'm kind of frustrated and
emotionally invested yes i need to
understand what the hell is happening
here and why this is so important i hope
you can see at this point how i have a
very very vague clue about what this
condition is but i'm already much more
likely to remember details about it and
also i'm much more likely to be
emotionally invested in this topic a
huge neurology topic which is just
another chapter in my book i could not
have cared less about now i'm like hell
yes this is absolutely awful let's learn
about it let's study more so now i get
into part three of my studying which is
the deep dive and this is potentially
the most controversial bits because the
way that i study difficult things is by
narrowing down on one specific thing
that i need to know about them and then
learning only about that and asking
questions around it as and when they pop
up so let me try to explain this
specifically i don't do overviews
because i find overviews tiring um even
if i'm excited about something they make
me bored about if i just read a whole
chapter or a whole essay on ms i
couldn't care less i will get bored
halfway and i will stop doing this but
if it's one very specific problem i'm
trying to solve i can get super super
invested in like sitting down for 11
hours and going how the hell do i do
this because i don't understand it so
i'm leveraging my very intense curiosity
rather than my vague boring textbook
understanding so what i do at this stage
is i think okay from all of these things
that i've read about ms what's one thing
that just stood out to me a lot and what
stood out to me was kind of her saying
specifically that oh i always have
another pair of pants and sometimes i
will urinate in my pants and my dog will
urinate in the house because so clearly
there's some kind of um urinary
incontinence associated with this
condition which is quite a curiosity so
i'm going to jump into the urinary
incontinence and what i'll do from this
day so i still know nothing about ms i
don't know i know it's something to do
with nerves and the brain because it's
neurology i don't know how it works so
what i'm going to be doing at this stage
is i'm just going to kind of google
signs and symptoms of ms and see and
then search this page for urinary
incontinence just on wikipedia i'll do
that okay so urinary incontinence is
mentioned there it doesn't actually say
where it's from so okay i'm going to go
now to
um another page on bladder incontinence
again
it doesn't have a lot it seems to be a
nerve thing and i'm thinking okay why
would the nerves get damaged and how are
the nerves damaged so
she has bladder incontinence because the
nerves are damaged how are the nerves
damaged now i'm curious about how nerves
work and what's the issue in ms
specifically so this is where i've
reached my limits with all this like
general knowledge um searches and this
is where i'm going to start going into
some very specific things to learn and
this is for medicine strongly recommend
the ncbi this is where i study most of
my things i don't actually use a lot of
textbooks but people will write like
long thesis summaries on different
different conditions so i'm just going
to go on to this condition for um
myelination because i figure out i found
out that it has to do with myelination
okay so i read about myelin interesting
what can happen when my lining goes
wrong this kind of gives me an idea of
what was happening with her but then i
go with urinary incontinence is that
peripheral or central
first i think okay it might be
peripheral have a look no it's not
peripheral it's central so i'm like what
the hell this makes no sense then i'll
go into deep diving things again and
again so what i'm doing here is jumping
a lot i go urinary incontinence why is
that oh it's because of nerves oh okay
what's wrong with the nerves they're
demyelinated what is myelin oh okay is
it peripherals or central nerves no it's
only central noise what the hell why is
that the case so i keep on jumping back
and forth from one topic to another
topic to another topic to another topic
all within multiple sclerosis but the
key and essential thing is that these
are all logical jumps that i am
personally making this is how i am
teaching myself i'm asking every
question and i'm then finding the
answers for those things which will then
raise other questions and then i'll go
answer those and this will take me from
a woman peeing herself with her dog to
me understanding the medical management
of
multiple sclerosis eventually but this
whole jump journey will be very personal
to elizabeth where my interests take me
what i'm curious about what i already
know what i need to search and google
this is all dependent on me so i'm
self-teaching myself by using my
emotional investment and my curiosity
continuously throughout this process and
this genuinely tends to be so much more
fun and also so much more in depth in
things than it would be just reading
this chapter summary somewhere now i did
say that this was slightly controversial
and this curiosity jumping is based on
many studies which say that you are much
more likely to stick to a task long term
if you are leaving it when you're not
finding it interesting and jumping to
another aspect of it and this is what
luqman and becker identified when they
said when i am stuck for one moment i
leave it and do something else with this
method i can work on different things
simultaneously i never encounter any
mental blockages and this is what is
super crucial with self-teaching i think
you need to have a strong curiosity
about the topic as a whole and then kind
of flick from one thing that you find
interesting to the next thing to the
next thing to the next thing you will
come back to the thing that you suddenly
left when it becomes relevant in another
point so rather than forcing yourself to
just take in all this information
without it sticking anywhere you can go
to it as and when it becomes relevant
and interesting going back to fame this
act of what i consider almost playing
around with the topic that i am learning
is what he clearly identified when he
was teaching himself and when he was
teaching other people he said physics
discussed me a little bit now but i used
to enjoy doing physics why did i enjoy
it i used to play with it i used to do
whatever i felt like doing so this is
super key for me to i only study what i
feel like studying even though i'm
technically forced to learn the topic
there's so much more freedom inside it i
can work with rather than what has been
given or summarized by someone else now
we get to point number four which is
questions or projects now this depends
on the sort of topic that you are
learning if you are learning a more
mathematical topic or a more physics
topic then i would potentially recommend
going for kind of building a project
with this or answering questions with it
specifically but if you're learning more
of a medical topic i would recommend
going for answering questions on the
thing itself so even though i only have
kind of an in-depth very patchy
understanding of ms which is mostly
driven by my curiosity and by the things
that i've read before and it's not this
like structured thing i still don't want
to go for the structure what i'm going
to do is actually try to approach
questions with it because at this point
i've already been primed with a lot of
things that i think are relevant but now
i want to see what the actual medics
think is relevant and what will come up
in my exam so i'm going to find clinical
case studies or i'm going to find
clinical questions that are related to
this condition and i'm going to try and
answer them knowing that i'm going to be
very bad at answering them because one
it's the first time and two i don't
actually know a lot about this topic yet
still but the reason that this is so
important is because as i am answering
questions i'm referring back to
textbooks and we're referring back to
google to answer those questions so the
process of learning things and the
process of answering questions on this
thing becomes interwoven and this has
been identified to be a very effective
way to study senka avron said that
experienced academic readers usually
read attacks with questions in mind and
try to relate it to other probable
approaches while inexperienced regions
tend to adopt the question of a text and
the frames of the argument and take it
as a given so it's actually super
effective to not have the reading and
the questions as to separate things but
to interweave them together against
circa ahearns said that ability to use
one own understanding is a challenge not
a given it should consistently be
challenging and it's fine for it to be
challenging for you to actually recall
things that you've just read or you've
just learned the very interesting thing
here is because i've done a lot of
priming and putting things in context as
i'm reading things on this condition i
can relate them back to the first case
or the first article that i read so for
example there's something in a mess
called otoph sign which basically means
that the signs and symptoms tend to get
worse with heat and this is where i
remember oh when she went on this
holiday and she was jumping off the
yacht so it was really warm that's when
her symptoms got worse so again i can
relate this sign to the first clinical
case that's a connection that's much
stronger than just another clinical sign
mentioned somewhere this process also
serves as priming for other topics other
neurological topics other things that
i'm just kind of anchoring somewhere in
my brain that i might come up with later
as there be some things that are
connected to ms and there are some
things which will just be dead ends but
don't remain there there'll be things in
neurology that will be connected to
these in the future the next step is
step number five which is the brooding
stage and this is a combination of
familiarity and lack of familiarity with
the topic so basically familiarity is
good of course because you need to be
familiar with something to understand it
but familiarity can also be quite
dangerous as bernstein recognized there
is a thing called the mirror exposure
effect which doing something many times
makes us believe we have become good at
it completely independent of our actual
performance we unfortunately tend to
confuse familiarity with skill so as i'm
doing more questions and as i've been
sitting on this for example a few hours
i might start to think that oh i grasp
this when i really don't because there's
a lot of other steps that i need to do
so what i do in this case is that i will
breed on this and what this means is
that i will recognize that it will take
me a lot longer than i think to absorb
this huge topic so i'm just going to let
it rest let it sit and do some space
repetition i'm not going to go into
detail on this because so many other
people have talked about it already for
example some days i'm just going to put
it in my calendar so when i wake up in
the morning i go oh let's think about a
mess and i'll just think about it as i'm
doing my makeup for example or as i'm
walking to the tube station or i might
kind of remind myself of it before i go
to sleep just so some part of my brain
kind of tries to refer back to it and
see how much i can remember and kind of
helps with those retention curves
because as time goes our retention or
understanding of the topic becomes less
and less and less and less and having
these little reminders here and there
either with questions themselves or
either just to prompt me to oh what do
you remember about this topic or explain
it or what was the case with selma blair
then i will try to kind of recall and
make these retention graphs kind of go
down a lot less than they usually do so
i'm working both with and against
familiarity i'm recognizing that it's a
bit of a dangerous one but that i also
need to do it so i keep both of these
things in mind and the last point is
creating false deadlines and this is
what kahneman identified as academic or
non-fiction tests almost always take
significantly more time than we expect
to learn them and every time that
students and even professors have been
asked how long they estimate will take
them to finish a text or understand the
text they always always underestimate
this so i keep this in mind that i will
have this fake illusion of knowing
what's going on but it will take me a
lot longer but i will create some false
deadlines in the meantime and say oh i
should learn all their maths within the
next two hours and then i'm going to
repeat all of a mess in three hours in
two weeks so i'll create these false
deadlines again and again knowing that
i'm probably going to forget most of the
things when i get there and that's
absolutely fine if you resonated at all
with my way of teaching myself something
that does this for you automatically is
brilliant they use so many of the
techniques that i mentioned earlier
automatically in teaching you different
sort of stem subjects it's absolutely
mind-blowing i would really recommend
even just trying it out for a short
while to see just how different it is to
learn when you are basing things on real
life examples and questions and making
things interesting rather than the ways
of learning and teaching that we are
used to in normal life and normal school
i'm currently doing the questions on
logic but there are some great ones on
mathematics and also physics which i
have tried in the past and are really
entertaining and fun there'll be a link
in my description which will give you i
think a 20 discount on brilliant that
you can check out or just look at it and
see if it works for you so yes that was
how i teach myself difficult things that
i usually would be too bored or
uninterested or definitely struggling
with grasping this has been the method
that i've developed for these special
topics i wish i had the luxury of time
to be able to do it for everything that
i study because i swear i would know so
much more but it's just unfeasible this
is only for those rare things that are
so challenging or so uninteresting to
start with that i need to really really
get serious with most of the things are
just a combination of passively learning
them somehow doing some exercises here
and there and cramming some numbers for
an exam so yeah if you made it so far
thank you so much for spending this time
with me i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day be kind yourself and others
and don't believe everything you think
thanks bye